Hi.
Today we're gonna solve a puzzle called the "Triangle Area Puzzle".
What we have is
4 different triangles where the hypotenuse is 3
And the length of 1 leg is 1 unit longer than the other.
The question is,
What's the area of a single triangle?
I'm going to give you a moment to solve this,
you can pause the video and take your time.
Once you're ready,
you can keep playing.
The answer to this puzzle
is that the area of a single triangle is 2.
The more interesting part, is how we can arrive at the answer.
One way you can solve this is you can work algebraically.
This is the long way to solve the problem
The steps involved, are you would label the 2 legs of the triangle as 'a' and 'b'.
You can then set up a system of equations.
One equation will be that:
a is equal to b + 1
Because we know that one of the legs is 1 unit longer than the other.
The other equation is that:
a² plus b² equals c², the hypotenuse squared,
in this case 3²,
by the Pythagorean Theorem.
We now have 2 equations,
for 2 unknown variables,
which means we can solve for 'a' and 'b'
and then the final step would be to find the area of a single triangle
which is one half 'a' x 'b'.
This is a rather long and messy way to solve this problem,
I'm actually not gonna go through the algebra,
if you do you'll find out the answer's 2.
However, I want to point out a much more,
elegant way to solve this problem, which is geometric.
So what we're gonna do is start out with these same 4 triangles,
and we can do a little neat trick, where we rearrange the triangles as follows:
We're gonna move one up,
this one to the side,
and shift this one over.
Now we notice something neat:
We basically have a big square,
which has a side 3,
and we have the 4 triangles,
and we have a small square.
From this we can figure out the answer.
We know that the area of the big square is equal to the area of the 4 triangles,
plus the area of the small square.
We can solve the area of the big square, 3²,
must be equal to 1² plus the area of the 4 triangles.
That means the area of the 4 triangles must equal 8,
and the area of a single triangle is 2.
I hope you enjoyed this puzzle, please subscribe to the channel,
and you can also follow me on Mind Your Decisions,
on my blog I post weekly puzzles on Monday,
there are also weekly game theory posts on Tuesday,
and that's my Twitter @preshtalwalkar.
Thanks for watching!